-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award- and
Emmy-nominated actress
you know from films like
"American Hustle," "Vice,"
and HBO's "Sharp Objects."
Her new film
"The Woman in the Window"
begins streaming on Netfli
May 14th.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Amy Adams.
How are you, Amy?
-Hi! I'm well.
How are you doing?
Good to see you again.
-It's great to see you.
I'm doing well.
Last we checked in was November.
We were talking about
your quarantine hobbies,
the skills that you picked u
along the way.
-Or not picked up, you know.
-No, right.
Yeah, I guess that was where
we ultimately ended up,
that you hadn't --
Have you improved at all
in the last six months?
-Not on those particular skills.
No, actually, my string
instrument repertoire
is still pretty limited --
-Gotcha.
-But I've picked up
some new stuff.
I started dancing again.
-Alright.
-It's an old hobby,
but it feels different
in my old body.
so, it's -- it has its own
set of challenges.
I still think, like,
I'm really...
flexible, I don't know.
Skilled. I'm not.
-Do you -- Is dance somethin
you do on your own?
I know you have a 10-year-ol
daughter, correct?
-I do.
-Do you dance in front of her?
-Um, not if she can help it.
-Right.
-I mean, I do dance
in front of her.
I actually...
She loves music and she does a
lot of lessons, but I really..
She has these beautiful feet
that would have been
great for ballet.
But I made her take ballet
and then I told her she coul
quit when she was 10,
and it was like 30 seconds
after she turned 10,
she was like, "Are we good
Have I done it?"
-I will say, nothing would
make me want to dance less
than if my parents told me
I had beautiful feet.
I think -- I think you might
have creeped her right out
-I think I did it wrong, Seth.
-[ Laughing ]
"Look at your beautiful feet."
-"Look at them!"
-"Don't waste
the beautiful feet."
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly. Exactly.
There's a line from a movi
called "Center Stage"
where the actress goes,
"You didn't have the feet,
I don't have the heart,"
and I think of that every time
I see her point her feet.
Like...
-[ Laughing ]
-You're actually in Irelan
right now,
which is very exciting.
You're shooting
a sequel to "Enchanted,"
15 years later.
How has Ireland been
treating you so far?
-It's been -- It's been
really wonderful.
I mean, it's definitely
different being places
during different quarantines
and lockdowns,
but it's been great.
It's been great. Yeah.
-And how is it to return to,
you know, 15-year-old
source material?
And you're co-starring
with Maya Rudolph,
which must be a nice addition,
as well.
-I am so excited
for her to get here.
I don't want to give too much of
the plot away,
but she's the baddie,
and she's...
I'm so excited for the cas
that we have assembled.
'Cause we have a lot of ne
talent and a lot of our old --
I hate to say
the word "old" anymore.
I mean, it was fun
when you were younger,
but now I'm like, you know
"returning favorites,"
as opposed to "old favorites."
-[ Laughing ]
-Yeah.
-Familiar faces.
-Familiar faces. Yeah. Exactly
-This is, you know,
slightly lighter fare
than maybe some of your
more recent work.
Is it nice to do
something like that again,
especially considering the fac
that very little has been ligh
recently?
-It is.
It is so nice to get to do
something that...
Really, the whole intentio
of doing this
is to create joy and hope,
and it's something
that means a lot to me.
And I was really reticent
to come back to the role
'cause I just loved her so much.
But it really felt like th
right time.
Like, Giselle --
I really wanted to --
to sort of embody her
and then see where she's a
and ♪♪ spread her joy ♪♪
You know. There we go.
-I know that it was, obviously
a limited Oscars.
You were not at the Oscars
but I had to ask,
how did you feel watching
your "Hillbilly Elegy" co-star
Glenn Close, a dear friend
doing Da Butt?
Is this a skill set
that you knew she had?
-I did not know she had
this skill set.
It does not surprise me.
-Yes.
-Glenn Close is
a woman of many talents
and she is, perhaps,
the coolest woman I know.
She's amazing.
So, it didn't surprise me,
but I was delighted.
-I want to ask
about your new film,
which is, uh, slightly les
light than "Enchanted."
We'll be right back
with more from Amy Adams.